bienvenidos veamos si podemos usar lo
que sabemos sobre resortes para intuir
cómo se mueven los resortes en el tiempo
y aprender algo sobre el movimiento
armónico incluso entraremos al mundo de
las ecuaciones diferenciales así que no
se asusten cuando lleguemos a ello o
pueden cerrar los ojos cuando estemos
ahí en este dibujo tenemos un resorte y
en esta marca cero en el eje indica el
lugar donde queda el resorte en su
estado natural en este ejemplo tengo una
masa m conectada al resorte y la hemos
extendido
este resorte por lo que ahora esta masa
se encuentra en la posición a en este
eje que va a pasar con esto como sabemos
la fuerza de restauración del resorte es
f
es igual a menos acá que es la constante
del resorte por equis que es la
distancia la posición de x comienza en a
por lo que inicialmente el resorte si yo
lo suelto va a retroceder cierto y lo
hará cada vez con mayor velocidad y
hemos aprendido que en este punto cero
se tiene mucha energía potencial en este
punto cuando regresa a su punto de
reposo natural el resorte tendrá mucha
velocidad y energía cinética pero muy
poca energía potencial
pero su momentum lo mantendrá moviéndose
y va a comprimir el resorte de manera
que va a llegar a este punto menos
todo este tramo
hasta el punto de que toda la energía
cinética se vuelva energía potencial y
aquí comienza nuevamente el proceso de
manera que el resorte va a ser impulsado
hacia esta parte hacia esta dirección
y una vez que regrese acá pues va a
acumular energía de manera que va a
regresar a este punto y va a representar
este movimiento ahora lo que queremos
hacer es graficar
está cómo se va comportando la distancia
con respecto al tiempo
entonces cómo se comporta x con respecto
al tiempo vamos a hacer una gráfica voy
a escribir aquí unos ejes ordenados
está este eje va a ser x con respecto al
tiempo aunque bueno normalmente nuestro
eje horizontal es x en esta ocasión x es
la variable o la función que queremos
conocer y este eje va a ser el tiempo y
en el tiempo cero
la posición el valor de x va a ser a y
va a llegar un momento en el que la
posición de x va a ser igual a menos a
no va a ser menor no va a pasar de este
rango de distancia porque voy a acotar
aquí en mi eje de la distancia este es
el valor de a
qué va a hacer
esta parte y en esta otra parte voy a
poner menos a que es el rango de
distancias donde va a estar moviéndose
mi resorte
ahora hagamos algo interesante vamos a
definir el periodo de
aquí ponemos periodo de
qué es la cantidad de tiempo que lleva
todo este proceso desde que soltamos el
resorte va agarrando velocidad pasa por
el punto cero se va deteniendo y aquí
tiene energía potencial que se va a
volver a
mostrar o transformar en energía de
movimiento y va a empujar el resorte con
la masa hasta este punto y así va a
estar moviéndose cuánto dura este
periodo de tiempo con este proceso bueno
tenemos entonces estos nuestros rangos
de distancia ahora vamos a ver suponer
que está t aquí se encuentra
mi periodo del primer ciclo de este de
este movimiento
si nos lleva 3 segundos de ir de aquí
para acá
tomará dos veces este periodo para
llegar de aquí y regresar a nuestro
punto a entonces aquí vamos a tener
la mitad ya que queremos ver bueno esta
es la
el té pero dio de tiempo pero quiero ver
aquí va a ser que cómo va a estar la
posición de mi resorte a la mitad de
este período donde se cumple
la mitad del proceso
entonces aquí tengo a la mitad
por lo que en este punto
el bloque estará aquí en menos
y la mitad de estas distancias será x
igual a 0 entonces tengo empiezo a
graficar mis puntos importantes vamos a
poner otro color para que sea evidente
en el tiempo igual a 0 mi resorte o la
distancia va a estar en a así que este
va a ser mi punto de partida
el punto en el que tengo
comienza el periodo o regresa se
complete este periodo está esta masa va
a estar también va a estar de nuevo acá
pues se cumple el ciclo de que regresa
bueno va a menos y luego vuelve a
regresar
a la mitad de este periodo vamos a tener
que este va a estar aquí en menos a por
lo que aquí va a ser el punto de migrar
y acá
a la mitad del periodo va a estar mi
resorte en menos
y bueno qué es lo que va a pasar aquí
vamos a ver que en esta parte de la
distancia va es cuando va a pasar por
cero
entonces a la mitad va a estar en cero
mi distancia en este ciclo
así que ahora conocemos estos puntos y
podemos unirlos más o menos así con una
línea punteada va por acá pasa por cero
del eje de la distancia llega menos a la
mitad del periodo vuelve a subir pasa
por cero y llega hasta mi punto de
origen
entonces tenemos una línea recta de aquí
hasta acá y cada que tenemos una razón
de cambio constante en el valor de x
podemos pensar también que tenemos una
velocidad constante pero tenemos una
velocidad constante todo el tiempo aquí
sabemos que alrededor de x0 cuando está
iniciando vamos apenas iniciar nuestro
siglo ciclo la velocidad va a ser
bastante alta y sabemos que en a y en
menos tendremos poca velocidad por lo
que aquí voy a escribir en otro color
nuestra función cuando tengo estoy en a
está en reposo esta masa apenas la voy a
soltar cuando el tiempo es cero entonces
aquí la velocidad pues va siendo muy muy
muy chiquita
conforme va pasando el tiempo la
velocidad va haciendo más rápida cuando
llega a cero a esta posición su
velocidad es muy alta y luego empieza a
bajar
y sucede lo mismo
esta parte por lo que va tomando
realmente esta forma nuestra función
y esta función tiene un gran parecido a
la función de cosenos la función
trigonométricas que es el cose no
porque si tenemos coseno de cero
es igual a 1
si esto lo multiplicamos por
el valor de an de la distancia
vamos a tener
por coseno de 0 va a ser igual
aa
es similar a esta función entonces
podemos definir este comportamiento de
la el cambio de la distancia
de esta manera
que es va a ser a jose no
w por el tiempo wv va a ser la velocidad
angular
y más adelante veremos que esto es
exactamente esta función cocina ahora
que tenemos de encontrar a esta
velocidad de angular que probablemente
será una función de la masa del objeto y
de la constante del resorte pero no
estoy segura
entonces quedamos que x la función de la
distancia con respecto al tiempo va a
ser igual a esto
y en en este momento puede embarcarme en
algo de cálculo una buena parte de hecho
ésta puede que sea la primera ecuación
diferencial que vean aquí si es en los
ojos si no quieren confundirse o vean
los videos de cálculo de cada academia
español vamos a reescribir esta ecuación
me voy a poner de hecho en otro color la
de la fuerza en el resorte
efe
quedamos que bueno vamos a reescribir la
cual es la definición de fuerza fuerza
es masa por aceleración
por lo que podemos sustituir esta parte
como esta reescribir esta ley de jugo
como esto la masa por la aceleración que
es equivalente a la fuerza que es igual
a menos que por equis pues bueno esta
masa por aceleración va a ser igual a
menos la constante de resorte por el
desplazamiento
y aquí bueno cuál es la aceleración
bueno tengo mi posición con respecto a
la distancia vamos a ponerla en otro
color tengo mi posición p le escribo que
es una función d
el tiempo cuál es mi velocidad esta es
la posición ahora la velocidad mi
velocidad va a ser la derivada de esta
posición entonces la velocidad
va a ser igual a la derivada
con respecto al tiempo
de esta parte que es x con respecto al
tiempo
o lo podemos escribir también derivada
de x con respecto al tiempo y entonces
que esa aceleración bueno la aceleración
va a ser el cambio de velocidad lo que
es lo mismo que la derivada de esto
último la derivada de la velocidad o la
segunda derivada de la posición entonces
mi aceleración va a ser igual
voy a poner aquí la segunda derivada de
la posición con respecto al tiempo
esto significa la segunda derivada
y esto va a ser igual
derivada segunda derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo aquí me quedo sin
tiempo para continuar con esta con este
desarrollo pero lo vamos a ver en el
siguiente vídeo